برايه ان الصينيه اتفقت السعوديه وايران
على استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه وعلى
اعاده فتح سفرتي البلدين خلال شهرين في
حسب بيان ثلاثي مشترك صدر في بكين ونقلته
وكاله الانباء السعوديه احترام سياده
الدول وعدم التدخل في شؤونها الداخليه كان
من بين الامور التي اتفق عليها الجانبان
كما تم التوافق على تفعيل اتفاقيه التعاون
الامني الموقعه عام 2001 اتفاقيه اخرى
ستفعل بحسب البيان الثلاثي وهي اتفاقيه
التعاون في مجال الاقتصادي والتجاره
والاستثمار وهي الموقعه في عام
1998 الدول الثلاث اعربت عن حرصها على بذل
كافه الجهود لتعزيز السلمي والامن
الاقليمي والدولي اذا هو اتفاقنا تكلل
بالنجاح بعد سلسله من المباحثات بين
البلدين عقدت في كل من العراق وسلطنه عمان
على مدار السنتين الماضيتين